where did you get your trading cards
printed so I got a pretty specific
question from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys Jason he was asking about
my trading cards I made a line of famous
entrepreneur trading cards I'll bring it
up close to the camera here called
entrepreneur heroes and I basically
partnered up with bloggers from around
the world and asked them who was your
favorite famous entrepreneur I love
baseball cards I want to create my own
baseball card series of French printers
that's what I did and Jason asked me
where I got them printed so the company
I used is great companies called custom
- trading cards calm the founder is
gavin easy guy to work with great guy to
work with has tons of great ideas and
had a really high quality product that I
went with
I was selling these and all the profits
went to support entrepreneurs in Africa
through Kiva and we raised over $50,000
to the campaign right now they'll do
have a lot of inventory left of these
and I wanted to see if there was a
creative way that you guys could come up
with - to get rid of some of these and
help out some entrepreneurs as well I'm
moving my office and I don't have as
much storage space in my new office and
don't want to lug all these things with
me so I'm gonna open it up I'm gonna
open up a pack and you guys can see what
these are all about and if you have a
creative idea for how to do a giveaway
then I want to hear it so let me open up
the pack so you guys can see what's
inside bring it closer so what I did was
I partnered up with bloggers and asked
him who's their favorite famous
entrepreneur and made cards around that
so first up we have Michael Arrington so
he's the founder of TechCrunch and that
was from John Chow that's his favorite
famous entrepreneur and each one has a
quote from the famous entrepreneur and
some details about them and a true story
then this one is Jeff Bezos founders
amazon.com that was from Andy Beal from
Andy Beal com then we have Jane Saunders
and Peggy short these guys were hard to
find the picture I remember having to go
and have a hard time finding their
picture they are the original founders
of the body shop I had a company called
body time as well and that was from
Danny Sullivan from search engine land
Jeff Hawkins and that was from Dylan 20
from Wired and then Howard Rheingold and
that was from VL aukmen
so each pack is slightly different you
can see again it's kind of high high
quality cards super glossy and it's a
nice packaging to each pack is different
and again you can check out the website
custom - trading cards calm I hope that
answered your question James but I also
want to know how can I use these cards
to help entrepreneurs because I got lots
of them left and I want to figure out a
good way so send me your creative ideas
leave a comment below let me know what
you think maybe we can have some fun
with it I'm excited to hear what you
come up with thank you guys for watching
and believe give it a thumbs up see you
guys